if you're going to be on the political
landscape you have to be extroverted
generally speaking and one of the things
that extroversion especially in
combination with less agreeableness
tilts people towards is a kind of
narcissism Jordan Peterson finally sat
down with Ronda santis they did it over
over video it wasn't in person
unfortunately uh but it is an absolutely
wonderful one-hour video and Jordan set
out I highly recommend you guys watch
the full thing we're going to show you
two clips right now but Jordan set out
to do that I thought was really nice he
said at the top you know everyone gets
it on policy you you you have great
policy you have you are competent you
don't lie the way politicians do he laid
it out really nicely he said what I
would like to know is a little bit more
about what makes you tick I want to know
a little bit more about your history
personality sort of how you go about
making decisions and it was really
really great and I want to to show you
two clips uh well take a look at the
first one if you're going to be on the
political landscape you have to be
extrovert verted generally speaking and
one of the things that extroversion
especially in combination with less
agreeableness tilts people to words is a
kind of narcissism and so there's a lot
of people in the political domain media
entertainment as I said who are in the
public eye who tilt towards narcissism
but the great leaders that I've seen are
people who are very good at
listening who are very good at building
teams and who might balance their
ambition with conscientiousness now it
seems to me very clear that you're a
conscientious person because you stress
hard work continually and you also say
that you enjoy it and those are
Hallmarks of someone who's conscientious
and that's a very good trait personality
predictor of long-term success it's the
best predictor after general
intelligence what I'm I'm curious about
the mechanics of how you go about
building a team how you've done that in
Florida and what you think you might
bring to bear if you were in Washington
I I read a fair bit about Donald Trump's
early year in first year in in office
and it was definitely the case that it
was hard for him to build a functional
team okay so that was obviously Jordan
sort of setting up what the whole
premise of the interview is going to be
now let's get into a a little more of
them actually talking about how you
build an effective team I don't need the
credit and in fact when things don't go
as well one of the things a leader has
to do is say okay I'm responsible for
that so there are there times and and
and and I I think you you can't be a
really good leader if you try to
micromanage anything I mean you've got
to set the vision set expectations and
you've got to give people the
opportunity to do it without you picking
at them and and that's the only way I
think you can really do well the flip
side to that though is that sometimes
when you delegate like that the the job
doesn't get done and people may do
things that that are not in line with
the vision and so what you just have to
be able to do is you just have to take
the necessary action to correct that
sometimes you got to replace Personnel
sometimes just uh internal course
correction but I think it's important
that you you praise the people that are
working for you in public and you censor
and private I don't believe in in
throwing people under the bus I think
they got to know that you're going to
have their back what's that thing I
always tell you when you hear the truth
like it's just kind of easy to hear and
you can sit in your chair and you don't
have to you don't feel that tension
because lies actually like they they
Fray the very nature of reality and you
know when someone's lying and here he is
calmly laying out how he believes you
should build a team and where you should
give give credit and how you shouldn't
throw people under the bus and all that
and you could really see and again I I
hope you guys will watch the full hour
and I hope that they do it again before
Iowa um because they were just beginning
to scratch the surface and Dan santis
talks about his childhood and his family
like it's really a different interview
than you've ever seen um but you get
that good insight into what he what
makes him tick and when you have someone
who actually is decent and is out there
trying to do the right thing what you
get are good policies and that's exactly
what we have here in
Florida